and we're specifically talking about
polygamy uhuh I wanted you to help me
out on you know how do you think I
should approach the debate because he's
quoting passages in the Old Testament
that not only are showing that the the
the
newy but also receive instructions yeah
but does he believe in the New
Testament yes he believes in the New
Testament well that simple if he
believes in the New Testament he can't
subjugate he cannot subject the New
Testament to the Old Testament
because that shows that he's
carnal-minded well obviously he's is
he's not a Believer and he doesn't know
that the New Testament is the inspired
lens through which we read the Old
Testament and interpret it and for
example go to Matthew 19 and read for me
verses 1 all the way to 9 Matthew 19
verses 1 to9 when Jesus has finished
saying these things he left Galilee and
he went into the region of Judah to the
other out of the Jordan large crowds
followed him and he healed them there so
Pharisees came to him to test him they
asked is it lawful for a man to divorce
his wife for any and every reason Jesus
says haven't you read he replied that at
the beginning the Creator made them male
and female and said for this reason a
man will leave his father and mother and
be United to his wife the two will will
be one flesh become one flesh so they
are no longer two but one flesh
therefore what God has joined together
let no man separate why then they asked
did Moses command that a man give his
wife a certificate of divorce and send
her away Jesus replied Moses permitted
you to divorce your wives because your
hearts were hard because it was not this
way from the beginning I tell you that
anyone who divorces his wife except for
sexual immortality
immorality did you hear what you just
said except for sexual immortality so
you want sex to be never ending
Everlasting what's wrong this is not
Allah in the Quran and the hoodies
immorality yeah okay reread it again um
I tell you that anyone who divorces his
wife except for sexual immorality yeah
and marriage another woman commits
adultery okay now you see what they said
like your Black Hebrew Israelite they
appealed to Deuteronomy 24: 104 where
Moses permitted a man to divorce his
wife and set her apart and here Jesus's
own words is this is not God's ideal
standard this is not what God wanted
from the beginning but God in his love
and in his patience he condescended to
meet his people where they're at meet
them at their level and allowed what in
God's mind was an evil that he tolerated
nonetheless right yes so why is he going
to the Old Testament and assuming that
the Old Testament is the standard when
the standard is Jesus Christ he's the
living Torah and he's the one who tells
us what is God's ideal perfect standard
for this age and the age to
come and he says notice because of the
stubbornness of your hearts God
allowed you to divorce your wives and
Remar because of your stubborn Wicked
Hearts but I'm telling you that's not
how it's going to be from now on because
I'm here to now call you to a higher
standard to bring you back and restore
God's initial standard for marriage that
he instituted at the beginning before
sin entered the world
got it got it definitely appreciate that
do not let him subject the New Testament
to the Old Testament it's other way
around the Old Testament subject to the
New Testament so then where does the New
Testament say it's not
polygyny but it is
monogamy it is one male one female 1
Corinthians chapter 7 veres
one5 1 Corinthians chapter 7 verses 1
and5
okay chapter 7 verses 1 five I'm there
now it says now for the matters you
wrote about it is good for a man not to
have sexual relations with a woman but
since immorality is occurring each man
should have sexual relations with his
own wife and each woman with her own
husband the husband should fulfill his
dut I to his wife and likewise the wife
to her husband now let's break that down
each man should have his own wife and
each woman should have her own husband
so you ask him you say can a woman have
more than one
husband and what is he going to tell you
no right going say no of course but then
he's stuck because Paul says just like
the woman should have her own husband
singular the man should have his own
wife singular he it doesn't say a man
can have his own wives and the woman can
have her own husband one wife for a man
one husband for a woman it's reciprocal
and that's why he then says a man is
obligated to satisfy his wife's sexual
needs just like she's obligated to
satisfy his sexual needs now
continue all right and it goes on to say
um the wife does not have authority over
her own body but yields it to her
husband in the same way the husband does
not have authority over his own body but
yields it to his wife what why doesn't
he say
wives because it's because of one wife
Paul is the context is
specifically one wife one husband so you
catch what he's saying here and notice
how fair the Bible is how Equitable the
Bible is and look at how the Bible
honors women unlike the trash called the
Quran and other religions and cultures
notice it says a man's body belongs to
his wife she has rights over his body
like her body belongs to the husband
it's equal she owns your body you own
her body just like she can't deny you
sexual pleasure you can't deny her
because she owns your body just as much
as you own hers talk about
beautiful Fair
instructions honoring women dignifying
women and not subjugating to be a floor
matat for the man now you read all the
way to five yep and five goes on to say
Do not deprive each other except perhaps
by Mutual consent and for time so that
you may devote yourselves to prayer then
come together so that Satan will not
tempt you because of your lack of
self-control goes on no you can stop
right there five now you understand what
he's saying so you cannot Den deny your
wife her sexual needs and satisfaction
you'd be sinning against God and
likewise so ladies listen the Bible says
you married women because this is sadly
common some married women punish their
husbands by refusing to have sex with
them causing them to burn and lust and
then opening a door for satanic
Temptation where they become ens snared
to pornography or other things which
they'll be held accountable for but you
will share in their guilt so listen up
ladies Paul is saying you better not use
your body as a weapon to punish your
husbands and listen up man it's not just
about you being satisfied in the bed you
better make sure she's satisfied fully
and completely because she has just as
much rights and ownership over your body
as you do over her if husbands and wives
were to honor the scriptures marriages
would be a taste of Heaven on Earth but
sadly we have even professing Christ who
use sex as a weapon weaponize their
bodies to punish their spouses opening a
door for immorality and entanglement to
sexual perversions may God save us from
that but here he says if the husband and
wife mutually agree to refrain from sex
for a short period in order to devote
themselves to prayer and fasting amen
but don't prolong it
because it defeats the purpose so let's
say you and your wife decide we're not
going to have sex for six months that's
too long then you're going to start
burning with lust you're going to now
have lustful desires thereby
nullifying your acts of devotion in
other words the point of prayer and
fasting is to a enter a state of
Purity a state of righteousness of
Holiness so you can become Holier and
more pure and less carnal sinful but as
you prolong intimacy your mind then
becomes occupied with sex and then your
mind can wander and therefore you defile
yourself defeating the purpose of prayer
and
fasting good points good points good
points so you get it
now I got it and the only thing is and
I'm sure I would have to use what I have
to let's say he's going to say I'm
anticipating nobody's going to ask me
say well show me where I say is a sin
but by showing him that is contrary to
the New Testament by default it be a sin
yes you mean I need to spell things
black and white well then show me in the
New Testament black and white where a
man can have multiple wives and it's not
sin flip it back on
him that's true so you're making the
assertion I can have multiple wives okay
show me a new testament where it says
you can have multiple wives and it's not
sin it's not
adultery you don't flip it on me you're
the one who made that made the claim
right yeah so that's the whole point the
New Testament interprets the Old
Testament the Old Testament is subject
to the New Testament and in light of the
Lord's own words Jesus who gave the law
to Moses Jesus said Moses allowed you to
divorce because of your stubborn evil
Hearts God in his Mercy stooped down to
your level and allowed and made this
concession for something that to God is
less than the ideal good for marriage
but now I'm going to elevate you and
restore that ideal standard of marriage
we're not going to put up with this
anymore we did it first a season but now
things go back to the way they were
before the
fall and that would be a point what
you're mentioning would be a point I
would use in terms of if since Jesus is
talking about that in terms of
marriage specifically divorce I can say
that same point in terms of polygamy as
well that he tolerated for season of
course well because what's his point one
husband brother he just said one male
one female that was the point he quoted
Genesis 127 and Genesis 2:24 he made
them male and female he said the Two
Become One flesh he didn't say the three
and four that was right there yeah it's
right there sure now when did polygyny
start when
did this act of marrying multiple women
began was it with uh
Noah or Moses no before that anyone
guess when did the first Act of polygyny
marrying multiple women
began anybody know let's see how many
the me I can't pronounce that person's
name yeah it's l from the cursed seed of
Cain none of which
survived so you notice polygyny multiple
wives started among l a murderer who had
murdered a man right he married more
than one woman so that polygyny started
from an accursed line a line
tainted cursed the line of Cain Who
belongs to Satan the evil
one you get my point
yes so they're arguing for polygyny
something that began
from the accursed line of Cain Who
belongs to the evil one 1 John chapter 3
verse 12 what does it say there and Cain
was of the evil one right yes and yet
polygyny started from his cursed line
because one of his cursed seed
descendants lch who was a murderer he's
the one who married more than one woman
and that line was totally destroyed in
the flood
so even the origin the root of polygyny
is bad it began it sprung from cursed
seed evil satanic
seed everyone got it
right and what does first John 312 say
read for me you would say that God
tolerated due to the stubbornness of the
Israelites yeah read 1 John 3:12 what
does it say there about Cain because L
is from the seed of Cain and that line
was
destroyed said John 3 first John
3:12 first John 3:12 do not be like Cain
who belong to the evil one and murdered
his brother so and why now my question
before you finish it this is the cursed
satanic seed can is of the evil one and
his descendants are cursed cuz for there
from the seed of Satan of The Serpent
and this cursed seed of Cain Le
introduces polygyny finish the verse and
it says and why did he murder him
because his own actions were evil and
his brothers were righteous there you go
so this is the origin of pyy but who
originated
monogamy God God originate monogamy one
male one female the two not the three or
four become one flesh so do you want
God's ideal for marriage or do you want
to look
to the Old Testament the Mosaic Covenant
which was a covenant that wasn't based
on God's ideal
standard of how the righteous should
live because God made a lot of
concessions and
allowances because his people are too
Wicked too stubborn too sinful for them
to live up to God's perfect ideal
standard even that standard they failed
miserably bringing God's judgment so it
had to await the Lord Jesus his
Incarnation his death and resurrection
and now by the Holy Spirit filling the
church he elevates us to meet that
standard so instead of him coming down
to our level he elevates us to his
level amen amen amen I definitely
appreciate that the debate is over buddy
that's it I mean there's really nothing
he's going to say he's tap then surround
it